GIVEN HER HISTORIC ROLE IS HER
PERSONAL REACTION.
>> MADAM VICE PRESIDENT, THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR HAVING ME HERE.
YOU WERE ON A PLANE WHEN THE
SUPREME COURT OVERTURNED ROE V.
WADE.
AS THE HIGHEST RANKING WOMAN
EVER ELECTED IN U.S. HISTORY,
WHAT WAS GOING THROUGH YOUR MIND
AT THAT MOMENT?
>> WELL, SO I WAS ON AIR FORCE
TWO, HEADING TO AURORA,
ILLINOIS, TO TALK ABOUT MATERNAL
HEALTH.
WE WERE WITH LAUREN UNDERWOOD,
WITH THE CHAIR OF JUDICIARY DICK
DURBIN.
WE WERE HEADED THERE TO UNVEIL A
PLAN BASED ON THE WORK WE HAVE
BEEN DOING TO INSURE THAT WOMEN
RECEIVE THE KIND OF SUPPORT THEY
NEED DURING AND POST PREGNANCY.
AND YOU KNOW, WE THOUGHT THAT
THE DECISION WOULD COME DOWN
SOME TIME SOON, BUT NOT AT THAT
MOMENT.
I WAS SHOCKED.
AND YOU KNOW, IT'S ONE THING
WHEN YOU KNOW SOMETHING IS GOING
TO HAPPEN.
IT'S ANOTHER THING WHEN IT
ACTUALLY HAPPENS.
AND I JUST ACTUALLY TURNED TO
CNN AND I COULDN'T BELIEVE IT.
I COULDN'T BELIEVE IT.
BECAUSE THEY ACTUALLY DID IT.
AND HERE'S WHAT THEY DID.
THE COURT ACTUALLY TOOK A
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT THAT HAS
BEEN RECOGNIZED FOR HALF A
CENTURY AND TOOK IT FROM THE
WOMEN OF AMERICA.
THAT'S SHOCKING.
WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT IT.
IN TERMS OF WHAT THAT MEANS IN
TERMS OF DEMOCRATIC PRINCIPLES,
IN TERMS OF THE IDEALS UPON
WHICH WE WERE FOUNDED, ABOUT
LIBERTY, ABOUT FREEDOM.
YOU KNOW, I THOUGHT ABOUT IT AS,
YOU KNOW, A PARENT.
WE HAVE TWO CHILDREN WHO ARE IN
THEIR 20s.
A SON AND A DAUGHTER.
I THOUGHT ABOUT IT AS A
GODPARENT OF TEENAGERS.
I THOUGHT OF IT AS AN AUNT OF
PRESCHOOL CHILDREN.
>> AND A WOMAN YOURSELF.
>> AND A WOMAN MYSELF.
AND THE DAUGHTER OF A WOMAN.
AND A GRANDDAUGHTER OF A WOMAN.
AND YOU KNOW, MY HUSBAND AND I
ARE ACTUALLY TALKING ABOUT IT.
WE HAVE A 23-YEAR-OLD, AND MY
MOTHER-IN-LAW IS IN HER 80s.
OUR DAUGHTER WILL NOT KNOW THE
RIGHTS FOR THE AMOUNT OF TIME
THAT MY MOTHER-IN-LAW KNEW THESE
RIGHTS.
WHICH IS THE RIGHT THAT SHOULD
BE WELL SETTLED, THAT A WOMAN
SHOULD HAVE TO MAKE DECISIONS
ABOUT HER OWN BODY.
AND WHEN WE THINK ABOUT IT,
EVERYONE HAS SOMETHING AT RISK
ON THIS.
FIRST OF ALL, IF YOU ARE A
PARENT OF SONS, DO THINK ABOUT
WHAT THIS MEANS FOR THE LIFE OF
YOUR SON AND WHAT THAT WILL MEAN
IN TERMS OF THE CHOICES HE WILL
HAVE.
DO THINK ABOUT IT IN THE CONTEXT
OF THE FACT THAT THEY WROTE THIS
DECISION, INCLUDING CONCURRING
OPINIONS, THAT SUGGESTS THAT
OTHER RIGHTS SUCH AS THE FREEDOM
TO MAKE DECISIONS ABOUT WHEN
YOU'RE GOING TO START A FAMILY,
THE FREEDOM AND THE RIGHT TO
MAKE DECISIONS ABOUT
CONTRACEPTION, IUDs, WHAT THIS
IS DOING TO MEAN IN TERMS OF IN
VITRO FERTILIZATION.
>> JUSTICE THOMAS DID WRITE A
CONCURRING OPINION SAYING THE
COURT SHOULD RECONSIDER OTHER
CASES OF PRECEDENT THAT PROTECT
SAME-SEX MARRIAGE,
CONTRACEPTION, INTIMACY, AND
MORE.
DO YOU THINK THAT THE SUPREME
COURT IS ON A PATH TO REVERSE
THOSE AS WELL?
>> I DEFINITELY BELIEVE THIS IS
NOT OVER.
I DO.
I THINK HE JUST SAID THE QUIET
PART OUT LOUD.
AND I THINK THAT IS WHY WE ALL
MUST REALLY UNDERSTAND THE
SIGNIFICANCE OF WHAT JUST
HAPPENED.
THIS IS PROFOUND.
AND THE WAY THAT THIS DECISION
HAS COME DOWN HAS BEEN SO
DRIVEN, I THINK, BY THE POLITICS
OF THE ISSUE VERSUS WHAT SHOULD
BE THE VALUES THAT WE PLACE ON
FREEDOM AND LIBERTY IN OUR
COUNTRY.
RIGHT?
THE RIGHT TO PRIVACY.
LET'S THINK OF THIS IN THE
CONTEXT OF THE LAWS THAT ARE
BEING PASSED IN STATES.
DANA, IN 13 STATES BY MY COUNT,
THEY WILL NOT ALLOW A WOMAN TO
HAVE ACCESS TO REPRODUCTIVE
HEALTH AND TO AN ABORTION IF SHE
IS THE VICTIM OF RAPE OR INCEST.
SO LET ME TELL YOU SOMETHING.
AS A FORMER PROSECUTOR WHO
SPECIALIZED IN CRIMES OF
VIOLENCE AGAINST WOMEN AND
GIRLS, IN PARTICULAR, CHILD
SEXUAL ASSAULT AND RAPE, THE
IDEA THAT AFTER A WOMAN HAS
ENDURED SUCH VIOLENCE TO HER
BODY THAT SHE WOULD NOT HAVE THE
FREEDOM AND AUTHORITY TO DECIDE
WHETHER SHE WANTED TO CONTINUE
WITH A PREGNANCY THAT IS A
RESULT OF AN ACT OF VIOLENCE IS
ABSOLUTELY UNTHINKABLE.
>> SO BECAUSE YOU ARE NOW THE
VICE PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES, PART OF AN
ADMINISTRATION THAT IS PLEDGING
TO FIGHT BACK, TO FIND WAYS TO
PROTECT WOMEN'S RIGHTS TO
ABORTION, I WANT TO ASK YOU SOME
OF THE THINGS THAT ARE KIND OF
OUT THERE THAT SOME OF YOUR
FORMER FEMALE SENATORS, SENATE
COLLEAGUES ARE ASKING THE
ADMINISTRATION TO DO.
WILL THE ADMINISTRATION ACTIVELY
CHALLENGE STATE LAWS THAT MAKE
IT A CRIME FOR SOMEONE TO HELP A
WOMAN TRAVEL TO ANOTHER STATE
FOR AN ABORTION?
>> SO, THE PRESIDENT RIGHTLY
LAST WEEK WHEN THE DECISION CAME
DOWN, INDICATED QUITE
UNAMBIGUOUSLY THAT WE WILL DO
EVERYTHING WITHIN OUR POWER AS
AN ADMINISTRATION THROUGH THE
EXECUTIVE BRANCH TO INSURE THAT
WOMEN HAVE ACCESS TO THE
MEDICATION THEY NEED, WHICH HAS
BEEN, BY THE WAY, FDA APPROVED,
AND THAT THEY WILL HAVE FREEDOM
OF TRAVEL AND THAT TRAVEL SHOULD
BE UNRESTRICTED.
>> YOU'RE GOING TO DO THAT
THROUGH THE COURTS IF NEED BE?
>> I'M SURE THAT OUR DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE IS GOING TO DO THAT
BASED ON EVERY STATEMENT THAT
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL HAS MADE.
>> CAN THE ADMINISTRATION EXPAND
ABORTION ACCESS OR ABORTION
SERVICES ON FEDERAL LAND?
MEANING PROVIDE THE ACCESS ON
FEDERAL LAND THAT MIGHT BE IN
AND AROUND STATES THAT BAN
ABORTION?
>> I THINK THAT WHAT IS MOST
IMPORTANT RIGHT NOW IS THAT WE
INSURE THAT THE RESTRICTIONS
THAT THE STATES ARE TRYING TO
PUT UP, THAT WOULD PROHIBIT A
WOMAN FROM EXERCISING WHAT WE
STILL MAINTAIN IS HER RIGHT,
THAT WE DO EVERYTHING WE CAN TO
EMPOWER WOMEN TO NOT ONLY SEEK
BUT TO RECEIVE THE CARE WHERE IT
IS AVAILABLE.
>> IS FEDERAL LAND ONE OF THOSE
OPTIONS?
>> I MEAN, IT'S NOT RIGHT NOW
WHAT WE'RE DISCUSSING, BUT I
WILL SAY THAT WHEN I THINK ABOUT
WHAT IS HAPPENING IN TERMS OF
THE STATES, WE HAVE TO ALSO
RECOGNIZE, DANA, THAT WE ARE 130
ODD DAYS AWAY FROM AN ELECTION,
WHICH IS GOING TO INCLUDE SENATE
RACES, RIGHT?
PART OF THE ISSUE HERE IS THAT
THE COURT IS ACTING, NOW
CONGRESS NEEDS TO ACT.
IF YOU COUNT THE VOTES, WE DON'T
APPEAR TO HAVE THE VOTES IN THE
SENATE.
THERE'S AN ELECTION HAPPENING IN
130-ODD DAYS.
FOR EXAMPLE, THINKING OF A
SENATE RACE IN GEORGIA OR NORTH
CAROLINA.
THERE'S A SENATE RACE COMING UP
JUST IN A COUPLE WEEKS IN
COLORADO.
WE NEED TO CHANGE THE BALANCE
AND HAVE PRO-CHOICE LEGISLATORS
WHO HAVE THE POWER TO MAKE
DECISIONS ABOUT WHETHER THIS
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT WILL BE IN
LAW.
WE SAY CODIFY.
PUT IT IN LAW SO THAT THERE WILL
BE NO AMBIGUITY ABOUT IT.
>> I WANT TO ASK YOU ABOUT THAT
IN A SECOND.
JUST A COUPLE MORE QUESTIONS.
WHAT I'M HEARING AND YOU
PROBABLY ARE TOO IS, WHAT CAN
THIS DEMOCRATIC ADMINISTRATION
DO RIGHT NOW WITH ANY EXECUTIVE
POWER THAT THE PRESIDENT HAS?
CAN THE ADMINISTRATION ACTUALLY
INCREASE ACCESS TO MEDICATION
ABORTION?
>> I THINK WE'RE PRETTY CLEAR
THAT TO THE EXTENT WE CAN, WE
WILL.
THERE'S NO QUESTION ABOUT THAT.
BECAUSE AGAIN, IT IS FDA
APPROVED.
AND IF IT IS PRESCRIBED THAT A
WOMAN SHOULD BE ABLE TO HAVE
ACCESS TO IT UNFETTERED.
>> WHAT ABOUT THE IDEA OF
FINANCIAL RESOURCES?
SOME FORM OF VOUCHER FOR TRAVEL,
CHILD CARE SERVICES, OTHER FORMS
OF SUPPORT FOR PEOPLE, FOR WOMEN
SEEKING ABORTIONS IN STATES
WHERE IT'S NOT LEGAL, BUT THEY
JUST DON'T HAVE THE MEANS TO GO
ELSEWHERE.
>> I THINK YOU'RE ASKING A
VERY -- MAKING A VERY IMPORTANT
POINT.
WHAT ARE THE DETAILS THAT ARE
GOING TO GO INTO INSURING THAT
WOMEN HAVE THE ABILITY TO
ACTUALLY TRAVEL WITHOUT
IMPAIRMENT, AND WE KNOW THAT ON
THIS ISSUE, WOMEN WHO HAVE
ACCESS TO RESOURCES WILL
PROBABLY BE FAR LESS IMPACTED BY
THIS DECISION THAN WOMEN WHO
DON'T HAVE RESOURCES.
SO THIS IS SOMETHING THAT WE ARE
LOOKING AT.
BECAUSE WE KNOW, FOR EXAMPLE, IN
TERMS OF HOW THIS IS GOING TO
ACTUALLY IMPACT REAL PEOPLE,
OVER HALF OF WOMEN WHO RECEIVE
ABORTIONS IN AMERICA ARE MOMS.
THAT MEANS THAT IF THEY'RE GOING
TO HAVE TO TRAVEL, THEY HAVE TO
FIND DAY CARE AND PAY FOR IT.
IT MEANS THAT THEY WILL, IF THEY
ARE WORKING, WHICH MOST ARE,
THEY'RE GOING TO HAVE TO HAVE
TIME FROM WORK.
IF THEY DON'T HAVE PAID LEAVE,
THEY HAVE TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO
AFFORD IT.
IT MEANS THEY MAY HAVE TO PUT UP
MONEY FOR A TRAIN OR A BUS OR A
PLANE, MUCH LESS A HOTEL, SO WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THERE
DOES NOT RESULT EXTREME
DISPARITIES OR ANY DISPARITIES
BASED ON WHO CAN RECEIVE CARE
BASED ON HOW MUCH MONEY THEY'VE
GOT.
>> AND YOU HEARD HER TALK ABOUT
THE ELECTION COMING UP IN 2022.
AND PAMELA, I ASKED HER WHAT I'M
HEARING FROM A LOT OF DEMOCRATS
AND I'M SURE YOU ARE AS WELL,
WHICH IS WAIT A MINUTE, WE
ELECTED THE DEMOCRATS FOR THE
EXECUTIVE BRANCH, THE PRESIDENT,
THE HOUSE, THE SENATE.
THEY'RE ALL IN CHARGE.
WHY NOT TRY TO DO SOMETHING NOW?
AND THE WAY TO DO THAT, OF
COURSE, WOULD BE FOR HER TO
ENDORSE GETTING RID OF THE
FILIBUSTER IN THE SENATE FOR
THIS ISSUE.
THE PRESIDENT DID THAT FOR
VOTING RIGHTS.
NOTHING ELSE.
SHE WOULDN'T GO THERE ON THAT,
PARTICULARLY I THOUGHT WAS
INTERESTING BECAUSE SHE IS THE
PRESIDENT OF THE SENATE.
SHE SAID THE VOTES AREN'T THERE
SO I'M NOT GOING THERE.
ONE OTHER THING AND WE CAN TEASE
THIS FOR LATER.
I ASKED ABOUT HER PREDECESSOR,
THE FORMER VICE PRESIDENT, MIKE
PENCE, AND ABOUT JANUARY 6th.
AND SHE SAID THAT